guillaume chevrollier merci monsieur le
président ma question s'adresse au
ministre de l'agriculture monsieur mise
la crise agricole n'est pas derrière
nous loin s'en faut
et ce n'est pas polémiquer que de
constater que la situation demeure
insupportable pour nos agriculteurs et
particulièrement pour nos producteurs de
porcs de lait de viande bovine
le plan d'urgence de l'été dernier
semble avoir eu peu d'effets sur les
crises profondes que traverse toutes les
filières animales
les éleveurs sont en situation de
détresse ils ne peuvent continuer à
travailler à perte
beaucoup d'exploitations sont en
liquidation on parle d'une sur cinq la
disparition d'un éleveur ses sept
emplois détruits dans le monde rural
c'est considérable avec un prix du porc
descendu à 1 euros 0,7 au lieu des 1 40
annoncés est nécessaire un éleveur
peut-il vivre quand une laiterie rachète
des militants de l'est
265 euros en ce début 2016 contre 330 en
2015 les 374 en 2014
un éleveur laitier peut-il continuer or
ces baisses de prix ne se répercute pas
sur les consommateurs et l'opacité de la
répartition des marges tout au longde
les filières est encore prégnante que
faites vous pour le label viande de
france est un réel un fait auprès des
consommateurs français
monsieur le ministre vous avez déclaré
hier dans cet hémicycle qu'il faut
donner de l'espoir aux filières par la
contractualisation et par l'engagement
des structurations je suis d'accord mais
passer aux actes les éleveurs français
payent très cher la désorganisation
l'excès de normes et de contrainte la
concurrence et les effets de l'embargo
russe
on sait tous ce monsieur le ministre que
les problèmes sont aussi européens et
que vous tentez de faire entendre la
voix de la france
mais les agriculteurs ne peuvent
attendre des années l'effet de votre
politique
ils réclament un vrai plan d'urgence
monsieur le ministre entendait leurs
appels au secours
merci la parler comme eux c'est stéphane
le foll ministre à l'agriculture dans
l'agroalimentaire et de la forêt
se prétend monsieur le député vous avez
rappelé que la crise n'était pas
derrière nous nous sommes encore dans la
crise cette crise c'est une crise de
marché dans l'élevage qui porte sur le
lait j'ai déjà dit et je vais pas
revenir sur la désorganisation du marché
puisque la fin des quotas laitiers a été
décidé je rappelle en 2008 mais il
s'agit pas aujourd'hui de revenir en
arrière c'est la crise aussi de la
filière porcine et vous avez rappelé ce
qui a été fait à un moment pour trouver
un accord pour essayer de voir si on
pouvait pas répondre sur le marché de
plérin fameux marché du porc à plérin à
une demande légitime des producteurs qui
était simplement d'assurer leur prix et
leur coût de revient
je veux pas refaire l'histoire là non
plus ce sont des acteurs économiques qui
sont des acheteurs coopératif et
industrielles qui ont renoncé ou fait
renoncer à ce qui pouvait être
simplement un objectif entre acteurs de
répartition de la valeur ajoutée au
profit des producteurs à partir de l'art
il ya eu un plan de soutien à l'élevage
qui a été mis en place
700 millions sur trois ans 180 millions
d'euros sont d'ores et déjà engagé plus
de 14000 dossier depuis le début d'année
est la première vous les présenter on
était à onze mille cinq cents dossiers
il faudra continuer à mettre en oeuvre
la totalité de ce plan et puis vous
l'avais dit il ya aussi des sujets
d'organisation de restructuration voient
aussi sur les grandes questions qui sont
posées compte tenu de la situation voir
s'il faudra pas non plus réajuster à
nouveau ce plan de soutien à l'élevage
mais dans cette dans ce moment chacun
doit bien mesurer que face à cette crise
de l'élevage
il y à des modèles des évolutions
nécessaires en particulier pour aller
chercher et garder la valeur ajoutée
dans la production ce qui n'a pas été le
cas depuis plusieurs dizaines d'années
c'est ça aussi l'enjeu le court terme
mais aussi le moyen et le long terme
merci monsieur le pénis la parole est à
madame marque